Oh, mais bonjour, je ne vous attendais pas.
Eh ben puisque j'étais en train de lire le
Trône de Fer, faisons donc une vidéo sur
le sujet!
Ça faisait un moment que je me disais que
je ferais bien quelque chose sur Game of Thrones,
un peu comme ce que j'avais fait en racontant
la vraie histoire des burgondes dans un précédent
épisode sans cuillères et sans salsifis.
Sauf qu'il y aurait teeeellement de choses
à dire sur le lien entre Game of Thrones
et l'histoire! On pourrait partir sur les
personnages historiques qui ont inspiré des
persos de Westeros, les événements historiques,
les mœurs, les peuples, la justice, la hiérarchie
sociale, les loisirs, la bouffe... Mais du
coup la vidéo aurait mis autant de temps
à sortir que le tome 6. Qu'on attend. Toujours.
J'ai donc choisi de vous parler des inspirations
architecturales, des bâtiments et villes
qui ont inspiré ceux qu'on trouve dans la
série, mais comme là encore le sujet était
bien vaste on va chercher ensemble lesquelles
des 7 merveilles du monde se trouvent dans
Game of Thrones. Et au passage on s'étendra
quand même un peu sur la société et d'autres
trucs, hein, on est pas ici juste pour faire
des tops.
Je préviens que cette vidéo contiendra quelques
spoils, donc mieux vaut être à jour dans
la série ou vous en tamponner la palourde
si vous voulez la regarder.
Pour cette vidéo je serai en duplex avec
une invitée spéciale, Arya, est-ce que me
reçois?
-Oui je te reçois très bien mais c'est Cat,
ici. CAT!
-Merci, Cat. On se retrouve tout à l'heure.
La première ville que j'avais envie d'aborder
est la citadelle de Villevieille, qui n'apparaît
qu'à partir du dernier épisode de la saison
6 lorsque Sam décide de s'y rendre avec Vère
pour apprendre à devenir un mestre. Villevieille
est située dans le Bief, au Sud-Ouest de
Westeros, à l'embouchure du fleuve Hydromel
qui malheureusement n'est pas constitué du
meilleur alcool du monde.
Comme son nom l'indique, c'est la plus ancienne
cité fondée à Westeros, ainsi que la plus
grande et la plus riche. Elle est fondée
par les premiers hommes et serait à l'origine
un comptoir commerçant qui se constitue en
ville par l'action des Hightower, la famille
qui dirige ce territoire.
C'est donc avant tout une ville portuaire,
mais qui se démarque aussi par deux bâtiments
hors du commun. Le premier est la Grand-Tour,
un phare de plus de 230 mètres de haut dans
lequel vit la famille Hightower mais qui sert
également de cadran solaire, et... Ben, de
phare. Il est si haut qu'on prétend pouvoir
voir le Mur depuis son sommet, et l'un d'entre
eux puisqu'il a eu plusieurs phares successifs
aurait été construit par Brandon le Bâtisseur.
J'utilise beaucoup le conditionnel, vous l'aurez
remarqué, non pas parce que je n'ai pas effectué
des recherches de qualité pour cet épisode
mais parce que Georges Martin n'apporte pas
de réponse claire quand aux origines de nombreux
bâtiments, quand c'est pas les origines des
personnages carrément. En tant que cité
plusieurs fois millénaires, Villevieille
possède sa part de mythes et de légendes.
Le deuxième lieu remarquable de Villevieille
est sa Citadelle, un ensemble de bâtiments
qui sert de lieu de formation aux mestres.
Elle est fondée par le roi Urrigon Hightower
qui lègue son terrain aux érudits à la
recherche de connaissances. On y trouve entre
autres un Foyer du Scribe où les habitants
peuvent consulter des écrivains publics,
un tribunal, un centre de soins, et surtout
une bibliothèque immense qui contient des
livres dont il s'agit parfois du dernier exemplaire
existant.
C'est dans cette Citadelle que les novices
acquièrent les différentes connaissances
qui leur permettent de former leur chaîne
de mestre, constituée de différents métaux
correspondant à leurs capacités: argent
pour la médecine, fer noir pour l'élevage
de corbeaux, bronze pour l'astronomie... Chaque
maison possède un mestre, qui lorsqu'il prononce
ses vœux renonce à toute ambition et prête
allégeance au royaume et au château auquel
il est affecté.
-Aaah, c'était peut-être pas une si bonne
idée!
-Le bâtard. Pardon, Jon!
-Ils sont dirigés par un archimestre, qui
informe entre autres le reste du royaume des
changements officiels de saison par l'envoi
d'un corbeau blanc.
Bref, vous l'aurez peut-être déjà reconnue:
Villevieille, c'est Alexandrie, et on y trouve
donc non pas une mais deux des sept merveilles
du monde. Pour info, les sept merveilles du
monde sont une liste des œuvres architecturales
les plus extraordinaires du monde antique
établies on sait pas trop par qui. Elle date
des environs du IIIe siècle avant J.C et
se concentre sur des bâtiments remarquables
par leur gigantisme. Plus c'est grand, mieux
c'est. Y'est cassé ou...
Il est intéressant de constater que l'univers
de Game of Thrones dispose de ses propres
merveilles officielles, dont certaines seront
abordées ici: il s'agit des Neuf Merveilles
de l'Homme, issues d'un livre ancien et qui
comptent: les murailles de Qarth, les Trois
Cloches de Norvos, le Long Pont de Volantis,
la Grande Pyramide de Ghis, le Palais aux
Milles Salles de Sarnath, le Mur, les routes
valyriennes, le Titan de Braavos, et les palais
d'or de Yi Ti.
Alexandrie partage de très nombreux points
communs avec Villevieille. Construite en -331
sous l'impulsion d'Alexandre le Grand, qui
aime laisser des Alexandrie un peu partout
où il passe, elle est ensuite dirigée par
les Ptolémée et devient rapidement l'une
des villes les plus importantes de la Méditerranée.
Elle est un grand pôle commercial, grâce
à ses ports, très peuplée avec environ
500 000 habitants. Strabon la surnomme «Le
comptoir du monde», mais c'est pour son
statut de capitale culturelle qu'elle nous
est restée le plus connue.
Ptolémée Ier décide de la construction
de la tour de l'île de Pharos, qui donne
son nom au phare. Son but était de guider
les navires, bien sûr, mais aussi de symboliser
la puissance de sa dynastie et d'assurer à
son fils le titre de pharaon.
Contrairement à la tour de Villevieille,
les Ptolémée n'y vivent pas, et elle est
aussi deux fois plus petite mais c'est toujours
plus facile de faire du gigantisme dans un
roman que quand il faut porter les pierres
soi-même. Il était constitué de trois étages,
contre sept pour la tour de Villevieille.
Parmi les Sept Merveilles, la tour de Pharos
est l'édifice le plus récent mais elle est
endommagée par des tremblements de terre
au IVe siècle et finalement détruite au
XIVe, toujours par des tremblements de terre.
Et évidemment, la deuxième merveille de
Villevieille-Alexandrie est la bibliothèque,
qu'on appelait à l'époque le Musée. J'en
ai déjà parlé dans ma vidéo du mois dernier
sur l'histoire des bibliothèques, alors je
m'étendrai un peu moins sur le sujet: la
construction du Musée est aussi initiée
par Ptolémée Ier. Il ne s'agit pas uniquement
d'une bibliothèque mais aussi, comme pour
la Citadelle, d'une école rassemblant des
savants venus de toute la Méditerranée et
étudiant diverses matières comme les mathématiques,
l'astronomie, la médecine...
L'objectif du Musée est de conserver un exemplaire
de toutes les œuvres existantes à l'époque,
ce qui était encore possible jusque l'apparition
de l'imprimerie si on en avait les moyens,
elle est donc aussi équipée de copistes
qui recopient ces œuvres en grec. Elle aurait
possédé jusque 700 000 rouleaux, rassemblés
dans la Bibliothèque mais aussi dans d'autres
bâtiments spécialisés. Malheureusement
elle est elle aussi détruite et ses connaissances
avec, par plusieurs incendies puis définitivement
avec la conquête arabe de 640.
Mais si on va un peu au delà des sept merveilles,
la Citadelle de Villevieille peut aussi nous
rappeler les maisons de la sagesse. Ce sont
des établissement qui apparaissent en terre
d'Islam vers le IXe siècle et qui rassemblent
à la fois bibliothèques bien plus riches
que ce qui se faisait en occident à la même
époque, écoles, centres de traduction...
Dans les maisons de la sagesse on enseigne
encore une fois la médecine, la philosophie,
l'astronomie... La particularité de la Citadelle
de Villevieille est d'être restreinte à
un ordre précis et fermé, alors que les
connaissances antiques et médiévales étaient
accessibles à tout savant qui souhaitait
les consulter. Par contre pour être un savant
durant l'Antiquité ou au MA, il fallait généralement
pas être fils de pécores, alors que tout
le monde peut tenter de devenir mestre s'il
le souhaite. Donc les deux se valent finalement.
Pour la suite de notre voyage à travers Westeros
je vous emmène aux Jardins Aquatiques de
Dorne. Dorne est le territoire situé tout
au Sud du continent, dirigé par la famille
Martell. Sa capitale est Lancehélion, une
cité où l'air est sec, où on transpire...
Le cauchemar pour la nordique que je suis.
A l'inverse les Jardins Aquatiques, même
s'ils ne se trouvent qu'à 15km de Lancehélion,
sont situés en bordure de la mer d'été
et bénéficient donc d'une bonne petite brise
marine. Ils sont construits par le prince
Maron Martell vers l'an 200 de la conquête
de Westeros par les Targaryens. Il est marié
à une targaryenne, Daenerys, qui n'est pas
celle que vous connaissez. C'est par ce mariage
que Dorne est rattaché aux Sept Couronnes,
les Targaryens ayant auparavant tenté de
la conquérir sans succès, et Maron Martell
fait édifier les Jardins en l'honneur de
son épouse.
Les Jardins Aquatiques sont composés d'une
galerie à triple arcade entourant des jardins
qui comportent des milliers d'essences. On
y trouve aussi des fontaines, des bassins,
où les enfants peuvent se baigner quelle
que soit leur origine sociale. C'est la princesse
Daenerys qui décide dès le départ d'y élever
ses enfants et de laisser les enfants de la
noblesse dornienne profiter de ces Jardins,
qui sont ouverts à tous les enfants dorniens
par la suite. Ils sont surplombés par un
palais de marbre rose.
Dans l'histoire de Game of Thrones racontée
par les livres et la série, nous sommes vers
l'an 300. Le prince Doran Martell, qui règne
sur Dorne, souffre de la goutte et décide
de s'installer définitivement aux Jardins
Aquatiques, délaissant sa capitale à cause
de son climat trop sec et pour que ses ennemis
politiques n'aient pas une connaissance exacte
de son état de santé. Ce qui ne lui sert
pas tant que ça en fin de compte.
Les Jardins Aquatiques peuvent être rapprochés
de plusieurs jardins historiques. Les premiers,
les plus évidents et qui ont entre autres
servi de lieu de tournage à la série, sont
les jardins du palais de l'Alcazar de Séville.
Des vergers y sont plantés dès le VIIIe
siècle, lors de la conquête arabe, puis
améliorés au XIIe siècle sous les rois
almohades et complétés du palais de l'Alcazar
sous le roi Pierre Ier de Castille. De nos
jours on y trouve de nombreux jardins datant
principalement de la Renaissance, ce qui fait
de l'Alcazar un mélange de traditions chrétiennes
et musulmanes de différentes époques. Ses
jardins sont classés au patrimoine mondial
de l'UNESCO depuis 1972. Même s'ils ne se
trouvent pas en bord de mer, contrairement
aux Jardins Aquatiques, l'eau y tient une
place importante puisqu'on y trouve aussi
de nombreux bassins et un système d'irrigation
perfectionné. Bien moins connue, l'Alcazaba
d'Almeria a aussi servi de décor pour le
tournage de la série. L'influence des Jardins
Aquatiques est donc clairement andalouse,
mais ce goût pour des jardins grandioses
bordant le palais nous renvoient à une référence
beaucoup plus ancienne et figurant parmi les
7 merveilles, à nouveau.
Il s'agit des Jardins Suspendus de Babylone,
qui auraient été édifiés par le roi Nabuchodonosor
II au cœur d'une région désertique en l'honneur
de sa femme, qui venait d'une région beaucoup
plus verte. Là, on se rapproche un peu plus
des Jardins Aquatiques. Ils seraient donc
datés des environs de 580 avant J.C., et
sont décrits comme une construction carrée
d'environ 120m de côté, en briques, au sommet
de laquelle se trouveraient des jardins et
bassins poussant sur des terrasses de différents
niveaux. Les descriptions des jardins sont
peu précises, et pour cause: il s'agit
de la seule des Sept Merveilles dont l'existence
est fortement remise en question. Les sources
antiques qui mentionnent les Jardins, comme
Diodore de Sicile ou Strabon, n'en sont absolument
pas contemporains et s'inspirent d'auteurs
plus anciens et dont les écrits ont disparu
depuis, c'est pratique. Hérodote, qui visite
Babylone au Ve siècle avant, n'en fait aucune
référence alors qu'il décrit la ville en
long, en large et en travers.
L'emplacement de Babylone a été redécouvert
au début du Xxe siècle, mais aucun chantier
de fouille n'a permis de retrouver l'emplacement
théorique de ces jardins, et les centaines
de tablettes cunéiformes datant de l'époque
de Nabuchodonosor et faisant référence à
ses constructions n'en font aucune mention.
C'est louche.
Pour certains chercheurs, il pourrait s'agir
en réalité des jardins suspendus de Ninive,
qui se trouve toutefois à 440km de Babylone.
Ces jardins sont décrits dans un bas-relief
du palais de Sennachérib, un roi assyrien
du VIIe siècle avant, et semblent correspondre
aux descriptions des jardins de Babylone,
d'autant que ce ne serait pas la première
fois que des auteurs grecs confondent les
deux villes dans leurs écrits.
«J'ai surélevé les abords du palais,
il sera une merveille pour tous les peuples.
(…) J'ai construit un jardin surélevé
qui imite les chaînes de l'Amanus. Il est
planté de toutes essences aromatiques, d'arbres
fruitiers, d'arbres qui font la richesse des
montagnes et de Babylone ainsi que des arbres
qui donnent de la laine».
Dans le cas de Ninive, on sait que les jardins
ont existé et étaient irrigués grâce à
des aqueducs et des canaux puisque la région
était particulièrement inhospitalière.
On ignore cependant s'il s'agit des jardins
décrits par les auteurs grecs, et l'existence
de jardins suspendus à Ninive n'empêche
pas qu'il y en ait aussi eu à Babylone. Mystère,
donc, mais on peut retenir que la légende
autour des jardins suspendus de Babylone se
rapproche fortement des jardins aquatiques
de Dorne.
Passons maintenant sur l'autre continent avec
la cité libre de Braavos, pour laquelle nous
reprenons notre duplex, Arya, est-ce que tu
nous reçoit?
-Oui, et je t'ai dit de m'appeler Cat ici!
Bon, alors tu veux savoir quoi sur Braavos?
Ça fait pas longtemps que suis arrivée,
donc...
-Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un peu de
l'apparence de la ville?
-Eh ben, je me trouve actu ellement devant
le Long Canal de Braavos, pas très loin du
marché aux poissons. J'aimerais bien vous
faire bénéficier de l'odeur. La ville est
constituée de plein de petites îles reliées
par des ponts et des canaux, et entourée
d'une lagune qui la protège de la pleine
mer. On y trouve un port de guerre, un port
de contrôle douanier, un port pour les navires
de Braavos, un port pour les navires étrangers...
Un type arrive derrière elle
-Eh, mademoiselle!
-Et puisque la ville est assez cosmopolite,
comme vous pouvez le voir, on trouve des tas
de temples de tous les dieux existants. Même
s'il n'y a qu'un seul vrai Dieu, le dieu de
la mort...
-Merci, Cat.
La cité libre de Braavos est créée environ
800 ans avant l'époque de la série par des
esclaves en fuite. Elle demeure au départ
une cité secrète durant 111 ans, jusqu'à
ce que le seigneur de la ville décide de
la révéler au monde en prenant soin de rembourser
au passage les navires volés un siècle plus
tôt.
C'est donc la ville la plus récente de toutes
les cités libres d'Essos, et la seule qui
n'ait jamais été possédée par Valyria,
la cité d'origine des Targaryens. Ses habitants
sont issus de peuples divers, de religions
diverses...
Elle devient rapidement l'un des plus grands
ports du monde, un grand centre commercial
doté aussi d'une flotte de pêche et de guerre
importante. Elle refuse toujours de commercer
avec des cités esclavagistes, et interdit
l'esclavage ce qui est logique vu le passé
de la ville.
La ville est dirigée par un Seigneur de la
Mer choisi parmi les riches familles de la
ville.
On ne peut pas parler de Braavos sans aborder
la Banque de Fer, une institution presque
aussi vieille que la ville et qui prête de
l'argent dans le monde entier en veillant
bien à toujours récupérer son dû. Pour
cela elle dispose de sa propre flotte et n'hésite
pas à recourir à des renversements de pouvoir
ou des assassinats en cas de non remboursement.
-Ça ne rend pas l'argent, mais je peux les
comprendre.
-Enfin on trouve en ville des tavernes, auberges,
bordels, et des tas de chats, partout. Ah,
mais c'est pour ça qu'Arya...
-Qu'ils essaient de m'attraper.
-Braavos est aussi connue pour son Titan,
une statue de granit gigantesque qui enjambe
l'entrée de la ville, servant à la fois
de phare et d'ouvrage défensif puisqu'il
est creusé de meurtrières. Il rugit matin
et soir et chaque fois qu'un navire entre
dans la lagune.
Certains lui prêtent même la capacité de
se déplacer, mais ce n'est bien qu'une statue.
On est pas dans les Argonautes.
On ne connaît pas sa taille exacte, probablement
une centaine de mètres de haut.
-Il pourrait facilement enjamber les murailles
de Winterfell.
-Ouais, je sais, tu l'as déjà dit là.
Évidemment le Titan de Braavos est fortement
inspiré d'une autre des Sept Merveilles,
le Colosse de Rhodes. Contrairement au Titan
qui ne représente pas vraiment un dieu, Braavos
honorant tous les dieux, le Colosse est une
statue d'Hélios, le dieu soleil . Il est
construit par Charès de Lindon sur l'île
de Rhodes vers 292 avant, pour célébrer
la résistance de la ville durant un siège
d'un an imposé par la Macédoine.
Sa construction est compliquée, le Colosse
mesure environ 30m de haut et comporte d'abord
un squelette de bois ensuite recouvert de
plaques de bronze. Du fait de sa fragilité,
il est la Merveille la plus éphémère du
Monde: 66 ans après sa construction un
tremblement de terre le casse au niveau des
genoux, qui restent sur leur socle jusque
654 avant de disparaître à leur tour.
-Un point pour Braavos.
-Contrairement au Titan, aussi, il ne se tenait
probablement pas les jambes écartées à
l'entrée du port. Cette image apparaît à
la Renaissance mais vu les matériaux utilisés
et la taille modeste du Colosse, c'est difficilement
envisageable.
Il était probablement plutôt à l'entrée
du port, façon Statue de la Lib erté, ou
sur les hauteurs de l'île.
Même si on s'éloigne un peu des Sept Merveilles,
je ne peux pas finir sur Braavos sans vous
parler de l'autre analogie entre la ville
et la vraie histoire de chez nous: Braavos,
c'est clairement Venise.
A l'image de Braavos, Venise est construite
à partir de quelques îlots protégés de
l'Adriatique par une lagune. Même si elle
est déjà un peu occupée par des pêcheurs
au temps de l'empire romain, elle émerge
surtout à partir des invasions lombardes
du VIe siècle qui poussent des réfugiés
à s'installer dans cette région pas très
hospitalière mais plutôt safe puisque c'est
déjà difficile d'y mettre les pieds. La
ville est donc, tout comme Braavos, multipolaire,
indépendante et constituée de différentes
îles, ponts et canaux. Elle se développe
d'abord avec la vente de sel et à partir
du XIe siècle elle devient l'une des plus
grandes cités maritimes, intermédiaire commercial
entre l'Orient et l'Occident. Elle est dirigée
par les grandes familles marchandes qui élisent
le doge à vie, comme à Braavos dites donc.
Comme à Braavos toujours on y trouve un arsenal,
dans lequel on peut construire 200 navires
à la fois, des chats partout, et de nombreuses
banques.
Elle décline cependant à la fin du XVe siècle,
avec la montée de l'empire Ottoman, l'ouverture
de la route des Indes et la découverte de
l'Amérique qui transfère le commerce vers
l'Atlantique.
Dans l'univers de Game of Thrones on trouve
aussi des pyramides, toujours sur le continent
d'Essos. La plus ancienne est la Grande Pyramide
de Ghis, la capitale de l'ancien empire ghiscari
qui dominait avant l'ascension de Valyria.
Elle figure parmi les Neuf Merveilles de l'univers
de Game of Thrones mais est détruite depuis
5000 ans au moment de la série. La pyramide
était une résidence royale, un trait qu'elle
partage avec la Grande Pyramide de Meereen
qui s'en inspire fortement.
Meereen est aussi une cité très ancienne,
prestigieuse du temps de l'empire Ghiscari
mais qui perd en richesse après sa chute
et se replie alors sur le commerce d'esclaves.
A l'époque qui nous intéresse, elle n'a
plus de roi depuis 10 000 ans: les nombreuses
pyramides à degrés de la ville sont les
demeures des Grands Maîtres de Meereen. Parmi
elles, la Grande Pyramide se trouve au cœur
de la cité. Elle mesure environ 240m et se
répartit de bas en haut entre des écuries
et entrepôts, des salles d'entraînement,
des appartements pour les hôtes, une salle
d'audience et des jardins en terrasse. Elle
est administrée par un sénéchal choisi
parmi les Grands Maîtres, jusque la conquête
de la ville par Daenerys qui installe sa cour
dans la pyramide et prend la place de reine.
Les pyramides de l'univers de Game of Thrones
sont donc plutôt des lieux de résidence
et de pouvoir, la forme pyramidale étant
propice à évoquer la masse et la durée
dans le temps. Les pyramides de notre monde
gardent cette idée d'éternité mais ont
des fonctions très différentes: la pyramide
de Gizeh, la seule des Sept Merveilles encore
debout, est un tombeau monumental bâti vers
2500 avant. Elle mesure 146m de haut, soit
100m de moins que celle de Meereen mais encore
une fois c'est plus facile quand on a juste
à décrire la pyramide que quand il faut
la construire. Les pyramides égyptiennes
étaient donc des tombeaux et non des lieux
de résidence, succédant aux mastaba, les
premières sépultures, et précédent des
tombeaux plus discrets comme ceux de la Vallée
des Rois et des Reines.
Cette fonction de tombeau se retrouve dans
les pyramides nubiennes, chinoises... Jusqu'au
nouvel engouement pour les pyramides au XIXe
siècle qui amène à la construction de tombes
en forme de pyramide, comme celle de Karlsruhe
qui abrite le fondateur de la ville. Dans
les civilisations aztèques et mayas, les
pyramides avaient diverses fonction mais jamais
de résidence comme à Meereen: ce sont
des temples, des tombes, des lieux cérémoniels,
sacrificiels, des postes d'observation du
ciel... Et les pyramides mayas et aztèques
n'apparaissent pas du tout en même temps
et ne sont pas du tout le fruit des atlantes
ou des extraterrestres, merci bien.
Le point commun entre toutes ces pyramides
terriennes et game of thronesiennes est leur
caractère imposant et officiel. Ce ne sont
pas des bâtiments du commun, elles remplissent
des fonctions importantes et ne sont pas destinées
au premier pécore venu. Sauf les pyramides
de la Grande Motte, mais j'ai pas très envie
de partir sur une comparaison Grande Motte
/ Meereen.
Et enfin, même s'il ne s'apparente à aucune
des Sept Merveilles, je voulais quand même
vous parler du Mur. Il fait partie des Neuf
Merveilles de l'univers de Game of Thrones,
de par son gigantisme et l'ampleur de sa réalisation
comme pour la plupart des merveilles terriennes
et de là-bas. Il mesure environ 210m de haut,
une hauteur si hallucinante que même Georges
Martin a reconnu «ouais, j'ai un peu exagéré».
Il coupe tout le nord de Westeros de Tour
Ombreuse à Fort-Levant sur 450km de long.
Sa particularité est d'être entièrement
construit en blocs de glace, recouverts d'une
autre couche de glace qui lui donne son aspect
lisse. Il est érigé environ 8000 ans avant
notre époque, peu après la Longue Nuit,
un épisode sombre de l'histoire de Westeros.
-L'hiver y était pire que jamais, et les
Marcheurs Blancs descendirent vers le Sud
en tuant tous les premiers hommes.
-T'es... Une sauvageonne?
-Je suis du peuple libre! Une vraie nordique.
-Oui, ben excuse-moi, je suis née à Lille
aussi hein. Bref, on ne sait pas exactement
ce qui s'est passé pendant la Longue Nuit,
mais il en résulte la fondation de la Garde
de Nuit et la construction du Mur par Brandon
le Bâtisseur, le fondateur de la maison Stark
dont la vie relève en partie de la légende.
Il aurait été aidé par des géants, ou
les enfants de la forêt, et le Mur n'est
pas seulement de glace mais de sortilèges
qui retiennent les Autres de l'autre côté.
-Et nous, aussi.
-Il est gardé par 17 forts, mais sa défense
diminue sous les Targaryens puis les Baratheons.
Dans Game of Thrones, le Mur sert à empêcher
tous ceux qui se trouvent au delà de passer.
Il peut nous évoquer en cela la Grande Muraille
de Chine, bâtie pour défendre la frontière
nord, quelle coïncidence. Les dates de construction
sont nombreuses car plusieurs murailles ont
été construites, au VIIIe siècle avant
J.C., au IIIe siècle avant... La Muraille
telle qu'on la connaît date de la dynastie
Ming et est construite au XVe siècle. Elle
fait maintenant partie des Sept Merveilles
du monde moderne, en tant que plus long ouvrage
construit par les humains. De nombreuses civilisations
ont construit des murs pour se protéger de
ce qui se trouve au delà, on trouve aussi
des murailles en Inde... Pourtant, le mur
rappelle surtout le mur d'Hadrien, déjà
de par la forme de Westeros qui ressemble
vachement à la Grande Bretagne. On retrouve
l'idée d'un peuple nordique plus sauvageon
que les gentils romains civilisés, la présence
de fortins à intervalle réguliers mais progressivement
abandonnés, comme sur le Mur... Mais le mur
d'Hadrien n'était pas pour autant un mur
uniquement défensif. Il était beaucoup plus
ouvert sur le Nord que notre Mur de glace,
et servait aussi bien de poste-frontière
que de lieu de transit pour certains commerçants
faisant route vers le Nord.
J'en ai déjà parlé dans ma vidéo sur le
Mur d'Hadrien il y a un moment, alors je ne
vais pas m'éterniser dessus et je vous invite
à aller la regarder.
-Alors si votre mur était plutôt sympa,
en fin de compte, on peut savoir pourquoi
le mien nous interdit formellement de passer?
-Parce que vous êtes pas les seuls dont on
se protège.
-Pfff. Une Stark. Pour moi, tu n'es personne.
Bon courage avec les marcheurs blancs, moi,
je file à Dorne. Paraît qu'il y a des jardins
sympas.
-Désolé, hein, c'était une intervention
non prévue...
-Ça me va très bien d'être personne, en
ce moment.
-Merci pour le coup de main, alors, et tu
me dis quand tu repasse dans le Nord!
-Très bien, faisons comme ça.
-Valar Morghulis!
-Valar Dohaerys.